Welcome back.
Almost done.
We're on problem number 19.
Let me read it out loud.
At a bottling company, machine
A fills a bottle with spring
water, and machine B accepts the
bottle only if the fluid
ounces is between 11
7/8 and 12 and 1/8.
So let me say O for ounces.
So the ounces have to be
between 11 and 7/8.
That's O, not 0.
Maybe I'll use x.
x for ounces.
That's an x, that weird
looking symbol.
And 12 and 1/8.
That's what B accepts if the
ounces are between that.
If B accepts a bottle containing
n fluid ounces,
which of the following
describes all
possible values of n?
So they're actually saying
n for ounces.
We could just say this.
So n is between these two terms.
And they give a bunch
of choices that involve
absolute values.
And what I'm going to do is
actually-- I'm going to draw
this on a number line, and
then I think the absolute
values are going
to make sense.
Let me do another color just to
change things a little bit.
So if this is the number line
and this is 11 and 7/8.
And this is 12 and 1/8.
And n has to be between
these two numbers.
n can be anything between
So when they're doing absolute
value, I guess you can see
that they're saying that-- they
have all these 12's and
all that-- and I think you could
immediately see that 12
is right in the middle
of these two numbers.
12 is right there
in the middle.
Let me do a different color.
This is 12.
It's right smack dab
in the middle.
And as long as n is a little bit
less than 12 or a little
bit more than 12, we're OK.
The machine B is going
to accept it, right?
So how much more than
12 can n be?
This is n. n can be anywhere
in this range.
Obviously if n is 12,
it's like perfect.
It's just like right
in the middle.
It's definitely nowhere close
to one of the bad ounces.
It's kind of the
perfect ounces.
The perfect number of
ounces in the bottle
of the spring water.
Let's see.
So how much more can--
it can be 1/8 more.
This distance is 1/8.
How much more can
n be than 12?
It can be 1/8 more.
And how much less?
Well this distance
is also 1/8.
So we know that n minus 12-- the
difference between n and
12-- and we don't know if n
is greater than 12, or n
is less than 12.
So we'll say just
the difference.
And we're going to take
the absolute value.
Because if n is greater, the
absolute value doesn't matter.
And if n is less, then n minus
12 will be a negative number.
But we just care about the
absolute difference.
We don't care whether one is
negative or one is positive.
So we say that n minus 12 has
to be less-- the difference
between n and 12-- and that's
just the absolute value of n
minus 12-- has to be less
than or equal to
this kind of tolerance.
You probably haven't done much
manufacturing yet, but if you
do this is the kind of thing
you'll deal with.
So it has to be less than
or equal to 1/8.
And I want you to play
around with this.
I mean you could say, well
n can't be more than
1/8 more than 12.
So you could say that n minus
12 has to be less than or
equal to 1/8.
And then you could also say
that on this side, n minus
12-- right, if n is around
here-- n minus 12.
So this if n is greater
than 12.
And then if n is less than 12,
then n minus 12 has to be
greater than or equal
to minus 1/8.
This might be more confusing
to you, and I'm debating
whether I should
even write it.
But these two things would
also translate into this.
But the big picture, absolute
value just means the
difference between
two numbers.
I don't care if one is bigger
than the other.
I'm just saying that the
difference between these two
numbers cannot be
more than 1/8.
So n minus 12, the absolute
value is less
than or equal to 1/8.
And this choice-- well actually,
it's between these
two values.
It can't equal these values.
So it can't equal these
values, so it's not
less than or equal.
It's just less than.
So n minus 12 is
less than 1/8.
That's choice C.
And we are on the
last problem.
Number 20.
Almost there.
The least integer of a
set of consecutive
integers is minus 25.
So the least, the smallest
is equal to minus 25.
The least is minus 25.
If the sum of these integers is
26, how many integers are
in this set?
This is interesting.
So I have minus 25 plus
something plus
something plus something.
And when I add up all of
the integers, I get 26.
So it's the least integer
of a set of consecutive
integers is minus 25.
If the sum of these integers is
26, how many integers are
in this set?
Well we start with minus 25.
So the rest of the integers are
going to have to equal--
this is an equation--
minus 25 plus all of
these random things.
So let's add 25 to both
sides of these things.
So the rest of the integers are
going to have to equal--
so you know, let's call it this
is I2 because this is I1,
integer 3, integer 4 plus
integer n, because we don't
know how many there are.
So that means that I2 plus I3
plus bup, bup, bup, bup, bup.
We don't know, a bunch.
In is going to equal-- I'm just
adding 25 to both sides
of this equation.
So that is equal to 51.
Let's see, the least integer
of a set of consecutive
integers is minus 25.
Oh, I forgot.
That's consecutive integers.
So we would actually know what
these values are, consecutive.
So I2 is going to be minus 24--
you could almost ignore
what I said just now.
Let me actually clear this.
I didn't read that
consecutive.
It's important to read your
problems properly.
So it's minus 25 plus minus 24
plus minus 23 is all-- and
then we don't know how high it
goes, but that is equal to 26.
So what do we know?
We know that we go from minus
25 plus minus 24 plus minus
23, and we're going to
go all the way to 0.
And then we're going to keep
adding that to 1 plus 2 plus 3
plus 4, and we're going
to add-- so you know.
Well let me write it this way.
Minus 25 plus minus 24 plus
minus 23 plus bam, bam, bam,
bam, bam plus minus 1 plus 0
plus 1 plus 2 plus 24 plus 25.
So I claim that the sum of all
of the integers from minus 25
to 25 is going to be 0.
And how do I know that?
Well because minus 1-- let me
switch colors-- minus 1 is
going to cancel out with 1.
Minus 2 is going to
cancel out with 2.
Minus 23 is going to cancel
out with positive 23.
Minus 24 is going to
cancel out with 24.
And negative 25 is going to
cancel out with positive 25.
And so the last term, 26, has
nothing to cancel out with it.
And that's the sum because
all of the other
terms canceled out.
So how many terms are there?
So to go from minus 25 to minus
1, that is 25 terms.
Then to go from 1 to 25, that's
25 terms. And then we
have 0 is one term, and then
26 is another term.
So 25 plus 25 is 50
plus 1 plus 1.
52 terms. And that
is choice E.
And we are done that
first section.
I hope you had fun.
I'll see you soon.